[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka mr. marvel and
this is the channel where we explain it
so you don't have to with spider-man far
from home right around the corner
more and more leaks about the movie's
plot and ending have started coming
forward and it looks like we finally
have confirmation of the phone's
post-credit scene due to some casting
news that recently came forth throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything that apparently happens in
the scene as well as what it means for
the future this is full spoilers ahead
so if you don't want the movie
potentially ruined that I highly
recommend that you turn off now every
leak like this should be taken with a
grain of salt but this seems to backup
previous spoilers and along with the
casting news it seems like a pretty sure
thing so if you want to avoid spoilers
whatever it takes then this is your last
last last chance to stop the video
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this I hope
you enjoy it now sit back relax and
let's get into my breakdown of the
post-credits scene of spider-man far
from home
okay so firstly the breakdown of the
scene comes from Roy G 575 who
apparently worked on the film and
recently leaked info to the Marvel
Studios spoiler subreddit this week it
reads the mid-credits scene starts off
in a dark room with chilling and
villainous music a defeated and sad
looking Mysterio looks out the window
from a skyscraper at nighttime the view
of the shot is within the building
looking outwards so you can't see the
building itself a voice is then heard in
the background which sounds Russian
which say something like he beat us once
but soon he is going to pay Mysterio
turns round and the voice is revealed to
be from the chameleon and his costume
Mysterio then says Dimitri thank you for
having me back out to you chameleon
replies with don't worry there are more
of us right then the music gets darker
with the vulture similar outfit is
homecoming with a few modifications
scorpion whose outfit is similar to the
comics but a few differences shocker and
a different outfit from homecoming that
looks more like the red and yellow suit
from the comic
and a man in a business suit who walk in
from another room the businessman
gathers the villains together and says I
have a proposal the camera pans out to
the outside of the building which is the
old stark slash Avengers tower which has
the name Oscorp in a large green font at
the same spot the stark logo was and it
shows for a few seconds so obviously
there's a lot to unpack from that the
subreddit is a hotbed for spoilers and
many of the things linked they're often
proven to be true and as the description
lines up with a lot of the leaked info
so far it seems like this is going to be
pretty accurate the businessman is
apparently none other than Norman Osborn
who has been mentioned in other leaks
and it makes sense going off some of the
things that have been tweeted this week
most notably the following tweet comes
from a BuzzFeed reporter which reads
still thinking about spider-man far from
home which might be my favs body film
now Jake Gyllenhaal is incredible a
force and the post-credits scene will
make fans of the original Tobey Maguire
movie nostalgic can't wait to see it
again so the most notable thing to take
from that is the sentence and the
post-credits scene will make fans of the
original Tobey Maguire movie nostalgic
whilst I've seen a lot of people online
saying that they think that this means
there will be a Tobey Maguire cameo I
think we can all agree that that's
unlikely with the actor pretty much not
being in a big film for the past 10
years it seems far more likely that this
is referring to Norman Osborn who was of
course the big bad of that original
movie in addition to this Marvel Studios
at the end of last year passed around a
casting role for a character Gong by the
name of the benefactor the call for the
character was a Caucasian between 40 and
60 and a note stated that the actor
would be required to shoot their scene
at the end of last year in Atlanta so
yeah a 40 to 60 year old white male who
is known as the benefactor and is
required to shoot a scene for an MCU
movie sounds like Norman Osborn to me in
addition to this the character has been
teased already in the MCU with Walton
Goggins mentioning that he had a
mysterious benefactor during ant-man in
the wasp obviously this is a huge thing
for the Marvel Universe and it makes
sense for the next step of the franchise
with Osborn becoming a Tony Stark like
figure
but for the villains the Marvel Universe
needs a new Big Bad and honestly Osborn
could quite easily fit that role well
seize a lot smaller scale and an ass he
actually has a better connection to the
world and therefore can probably cause
more problems for the heroes
due to his wealth power and
infrastructure I really think that if
this comes true it's an awesome way to
take the series and it just gets me so
hyped to see what will come down the
line
spider-man far from home is the end of
phase 3 and it's the best time to
introduce a new villain that will
definitely get fans excited for what's
to come
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the news and if you believe it or not
comment below and let me know and if you
love this video 3000 then please give it
a thumbs up and make sure you check out
my full breakdown of everything that we
know so far about phase 4 which would be
linked at the end it covers all of the
upcoming slay and it's definitely worth
watching if you want to know more you've
also just launched a merchandise section
on the channel so if you want to support
us and get something back make sure you
click the links in the boxes below it
all goes towards helping to make videos
like this and we massively massively
appreciate it so thank you this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]